Oh, sorry.
No more loops, by the way.
I'm compiling shaders right now.
I'm compiling shaders at the moment in the background.
Sorry.
Okay, so the reason why we had so many loops is that I forgot how to stream.
I was like, I should get some water.
And I was like, ooh, I'm a little thirsty.
And then I was like, ooh, I should close my 200 tabs that I have open.
I had like 70 tabs opened on my, you know, since I haven't streamed in a while.
I had like 70 plus tabs opened on my PC.
So I was like, I should clean that up.
While I was like, the waiting room, the intro was going on.
And I was just like, I should close some of these.
I was like, oh, yeah.
I'm pretty sure, like, I just read the reviews.
And like, there was a performance issues with soccer.
He had a little performance anxiety.
So I was like, ooh, I should.
Oh, yeah, sorry.
I should get that fixed.
I should make sure my PC is not, you know, on fire or anything.
So I'm compiling shaders right now in the background.
So, yeah, apparently they already put our patch right now for it.
Give me a second, I need to sneeze real quick.
Oh, God.
Oh, no, come on.
Give me that sneeze.
No!
Okay, I had like, you'll want to sneeze, but you can't issue.
So, it's been a while, guys.
It's been a while.
I'm sorry.
It has been, I know.
A lot has been going.
I was not feeling great when I came back.
Because, you know, I got sick.
And I really hate taking breaks.
I really do.
And like, you know, I didn't put any schedule up.
And then I sort of like, I was like, all right.
For those who don't follow me on Twitter.
Because like, you know, I don't blame you.
You know, I don't blame you.
And I don't have blue skies.
Or anything.
The newest social media platform.
I barely could use Twitter alone.
Let alone like, another one.
And I know some of you guys don't use Twitter.
So you're like, we have a stream today?
Yes, yesterday I was like, yeah, stalker stream.
And then I was like, oh shit.
Okay, I should make a waiting room for that.
But the reason why I didn't have the waiting room early.
Was because if you aren't using 50 plus tabs, you aren't doing it.
Exactly.
Shaded Heart, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So the reason why we didn't have the waiting room earlier.
Was because this stream, I'm sorry.
The shaders is like, it's still compiled.
I'll show you guys what we're looking at right now.
Because it's still compiling.
If I'm like, if I'm like, 5 FPS right now.
It's compiling shaders.
Compiling is real.
Anyway, so the reason why it took so long to make my waiting room.
You know, I could have made the waiting room yesterday.
Was because, oh my god.
I hate this.
It's like killing me.
Seeing myself at like 5 FPS right now is fucking killing me.
Was because, today we're sponsored.
Weird, sorry.
By the way, I was really tired.
Because I went to bed at like 6 in the morning today.
And I went to bed yesterday at 6 in the morning.
So that's why I took a 40 minute nap.
I took a 40 minute nap before the stream was starting.
And because of that, I literally woke up 10 minutes before the stream was supposed to start.
Oh my god, thank god.
I'm sorry, I'm trying to remember how to stream.
No, no, no, it's not because of Overwatch, guys.
Guys, you can't always blame Overwatch.
Sometimes it's just not Overwatch, guys.
Sometimes, I know it's crazy to think about.
But sometimes, it's not just about Overwatch.
There are other things, okay?
There are other things this time.
It's not just Overwatch.
There are other issues.
But anyway, anyway.
I had a lot of work stuff to catch up on.
So that's why there's no schedule at the moment.
Because I was sick, I was sick.
And I have a lot of work stuff.
And I have a sponsor today.
So, obviously, I couldn't be like, no stream.
Because I signed a contract.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Nino, thank you for the super chat.
Yesterday was my birthday.
Gonna try and buy new PC parts to fit the higher case.
I'm excited to watch the console next month.
Oh my god, I'm so happy.
You got so much stuff.
There's more stuff that just came out.
Nino, lucky for you.
There's more things that just came out.
Sorry, there's a lot of things.
There's a lot of things.
But happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Nino.
Yeah!
So today, we are sponsored by MSI.
Yes, MSI.
The PC slash monitor slash a lot of PC related company.
They sponsored me today to play Stalker during launch day.
So they graciously provided us a couple of Stalker codes.
So I will be giving out key codes, game codes for Stalker 2 at the end of the stream.
So you guys can redeem it.
It is very limited.
I think there's like five codes.
So five lucky dragoons would be able to receive a Stalker 2 for free.
And basically, it is in regards to the promotion of their new monitor.
So if you purchase their monitor and watch a trailer, you can redeem Stalker 2 along with a free copy of Stalker 2.
Plus $30 for your Steam wallet if you purchase one of their monitors.
So it's like a special promotion with the game on launch.
You know, it's great because I was going to play Stalker 2 anyway.
But now I get paid to play Stalker 2.
So...
And so, it's like, you know, it all worked out in the end.
Because I was originally thinking of playing Stalker 2 on launch.
But now I'm sponsored to play Stalker 2 on launch.
So it works out.
I mean, to be fair, I would like...
I'm not like alive at the moment.
I'm still like fucked up right now like health-wise.
So like, it got so bad in the beginning when I first came back.
Because I think I overdid it during the rush stream.
Because I was like, you know, I was like forcing myself to stream the last two days.
Because like, I felt really bad that I wasn't able to stream the rush drops as much as I would have liked.
At the end of the last day of the rush stream, I was coughing a lot.
So to the point where like, I think at night, I like actually like got to the point where I coughed myself.
Like to the point where I threw up because I was coughing so much.
So I was like, okay, I really, I should take a break.
I really hate taking breaks.
And I really hate it because I was gone for so long.
I was already gone for so long.
And I was like, ah!
But like, I needed to.
I still haven't gone to the doctors, guys.
I know.
No, you don't understand.
You don't understand.
I have a good excuse as to why I haven't gone to the doctors.
It's because if you're Canadian and you don't have a private doctor.
And you don't have like a private doctor, like a consistent doctor where you're like a return patient.
It is very, very hard to find a doctor that would take new patients.
It is incredibly difficult.
And even if they do, you have to wait at least like a couple of weeks to get an appointment.
So, so I was like, I called, I called like two to three doctors.
And they're like, we won't be able to see you until like maybe two to three weeks.
And I was like, I might as well like.
No, they're not walk-ins.
That's the thing.
The walk-ins are either incredibly limited or they don't provide, they don't provide walk-ins near me.
It's like a lot, they don't provide walk-ins near me.
So, so it's just like, I was just like, well, I might be better by then.
I don't fucking know.
You guys are like, well, but you guys have free health care.
Yeah, free health.
Okay, I was talking to like one of my friends about it.
I was talking to one of my friends about it because like she was also having coughing issues.
And I was like, I was like, yeah, I got it too.
I have like really bad coughing now.
And then we're talking about like, you know, like finding private doctors here, like filing family doctors or like private doctors here is so fucking hard.
Because like, you know, they norm.
It takes so long to actually like want to see like they'll take new patients or anything.
And then they're like, we're like, oh, yeah, like I had like an issue with something.
And I just and then she was like, I decided to try out like, you know, she was like, I decided to try out.
Like the free free health care part of the free health care.
And then she was like, yeah.
And then I waited.
I waited like two months.
And then when I finally got there, the doctor was like, oh, this is not like you need to go to a different doctor.
This is not like my specialty.
Like what you have right now is not my specialty.
So you got to go to a different doctor.
And then she was like, why the fuck?
Why did I wait two months?
Yeah.
So that's like you guys.
I think, wow, Canada, you have free health care, but by free, you gotta wait a long time to be able to access the free part.
It's not like it's not like you you get it right away.
We still gotta we still gotta wait.
We still gotta wait.
To be fair, you guys in America, you guys gotta wait two months and then pay like two thousand dollars.
So like it's a little bit better over here.
It's a little better because at least we don't have to pay for it.
Like we just gotta wait.
But you guys gotta wait and pay for it.
So like that's like the only thing that's like better.
Only two thousand?
Doki, you're thinking about 2000 America, not 2024 America.
Oh my God.
But anyway, so yeah, so I haven't seen a doctor yet about it.
So that's why like this week is a little weird.
I know we have a few confirmed streams that got announced already by like others.
Tomorrow, I don't know if I'm streaming tomorrow, but Friday, Fillion invited me and Doobie to do a collab with her.
So like I'm not sure.
I don't I think it's confirmed because like I'm not sure because like when she asked when she invited me, I told her I'm sick.
I was like, she's like, do you want to play with Doobie and I?
And I was like, bro, I just threw up.
It's like she asked me on like a thing like on Sunday or Monday.
I was like, I just threw up, Fillion.
I don't know.
And she was like, oh man, like I was like, we'll see.
And I was like, the day after that, I was like, I'll let you know tomorrow.
And then like, and then I was like, and I was like, you know what?
It's Friday.
It's like a couple of days.
I have a couple of days to recover.
So I was like, you know what?
It's Friday.
It's Friday, Friday.
And I was just like, I think by then I'll be OK.
Like, I was like, I think I'll be OK.
And so, yeah.
So like, I believe Doobie's not streaming her POV because she said like, you know, she has like her whole internet thing.
Because I mean, I was like, wait, is Doobie going to be OK?
Because I know she has like internet issues and stuff.
And Fillion said, yeah, yeah, it should be fine.
And Doobie was like, yeah, most likely if it gets bad, she won't be streaming her POV.
So, but yeah, it's going to be like me.
I don't know.
I think we're getting a fourth player, but we're like still deciding who to bring as a fourth.
But yeah, Fillion invited me and Doobie to play Kingdom of Life 2.
So yes, that is a confirmed stream on Friday.
I think it's at 3 p.m.
PST.
I gotta look back at the thing again.
And then on Saturday, I know you guys might forget about this, but you guys don't know.
We have an Apex custom on the 30th that I'm organizing.
That is like has been the most hellish thing to organize so far.
I've never had a rougher time organizing an event because I had so many other things going on at the moment.
So I had like a lot, like it was just very unlucky because I had a lot of other stuff going around, going around at the time trying to organize this custom.
But on Saturday, I will most likely be announcing the teams and the participants and the rules and everything.
So everything about the custom will be announced on Saturday and on and then the custom itself will be on the 30th.
So that's like the tentative schedule at the moment.
I still have no idea if I'm going to be streaming tomorrow because I am still not okay.
I think you guys can hear from my voice that I'm still not okay.
But like we're gonna fucking make it guys.
We're gonna make it.
By the way guys, I know like, you know, by the way, I hope you guys don't forget, but I am sponsored today.
So a huge shout out to MSI for sponsoring me to play, to check out Stalker 2.
They actually sent me one of the monitors that is in the promotion.
It's ginormous.
I've never played on such a big monitor before and it's like, it's honestly been really cool to use that monitor and everything.
So yeah, I endorse it.
I actually got a chance to use it and everything.
It's actually been like, it's been like really cool using one of the monitors because I never used an MSI monitor before.
So it was a great experience and I mean it's free.
That's the best part.
I sure do love free stuff.
And yeah, and you guys should really, you know, if you want to support me, support MSI, support this stream, you should check out their monitors.
If you're here to game, they have really good monitors for gaming regarding refresh rate and just the response time and everything.
They're really good for that.
So it's more so, especially if you're really into gaming-wise and want a good monitor with good hertz, good refresh rate, good reaction time to everything.
And I would highly check out the MSI monitor.
Anyway, let's check out Stalker.
That's literally like the sponsored part of the portion.
So now, we're gaming.
I love MSI.
They're literally like, just play the game for as long as you want.
Like, we just want you to talk about the monitor.
And I'm like, cool.
Now I can talk my shit.
Genji, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Loose guidelines, let's go.
Rube, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I love the original Stalker games.
Love the streams.
Thank you for the super chat, Rube.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, let's check out how we're going to do this.
I guess that should be fine.
We're going to play in English, guys.
I'm not reading.
I'm sorry.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hope you get well soon, Doki.
Stalker is my favorite game series.
I was playing two for almost ten hours since the launch.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, that means like, it might be...
I never played the original Stalker series.
So, I've actually been wanting to for a while to play the original Stalker series.
But, time.
Time and I'm stuck in Silent Hill.
Like, I will never leave the hell.
It's 2025 and I'm still here.
It's going to be 2025.
And we're still going to be stuck in Silent Hill.
I was like, Gordon, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
It's my birthday.
I couldn't ask for a better birthday present than the waifu cup dropping and my oshi streaming today.
It's been amazing watching you this year.
Here's to another year of great stream.
Also, vote Doki for VTuber of the year.
Thank you for the magenta soup, Gordon.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Gordon.
Yeah!
By the way, I almost forgot to tell you guys the most important part.
I have metal forks now.
Still no plates though.
Baby steps.
I have metal forks now.
I don't have plates still.
I'm still using paper plates.
But at least I have utensils.
I have utensils.
Okay, guys?
I'm actually making progress to a functioning human being.
Alright.
Thank you for pre-ordering.
Yay!
I also got a free copy of Stalker too.
Thank you, Emisa.
Thank you.
And you too!
What the fuck?
Rookie?
Oh, wait.
There's like...
No, maybe...
No, maybe I can do...
Okay.
I was gonna be like, rookie!
And then the next level is literally Stalker and Veteran.
So I'm like, oh, wait.
I actually don't know if rookie is...
Maybe I deserve to be in rookie level.
I don't fucking...
I don't know.
Okay.
Let's make it large because I feel like we need that.
Hit indicator.
Compass.
Ammo.
I've never played...
Like I said, I've never played Stalker before.
So like, okay.
Maybe not that.
I'll try...
Okay, let's get motion blur at zero.
Oh, wait.
Depth of field.
Okay, reset this though.
I think I gotta reset this.
I fucked up the settings already for this.
Motion blur quality low.
Can I turn it off?
Motion blur...
Zero.
Medium.
Performance boost.
We'll figure this out when we adjust this at another time.
But we gotta get the motion blur out of the way.
F.
Full screen borderless.
Full screen exclusive.
Okay.
Gotta get full screen exclusive.
Should field of view be at 90?
I don't know.
Any Stalker pros know if...
Know if I should do it at 90?
Alright, sound.
Mute all.
Also, is sound guy even alive right now?
It's been a while, sound guy.
I don't even know if you're still alive.
Does sound guy still know how to do sound things?
Who knows?
Alright, sound controls.
Mouth sensitivity.
I'm just gonna put it at 8 just in case.
Just in case.
I need to make sure it's...
Hold.
Hold breath.
Hold breath?
Wait, what?
Hold to walk.
Lean.
Oh, okay.
I just don't see sound guy, guys.
I don't...
Guys, we have an issue.
I don't think sound guy is alive anymore.
Where...
Where is he?
Okay, this is...
We're gonna have a little bit of an issue.
Oh, wait, what?
I didn't confirm?
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Let's do...
We have backup sound guy?
We do?
Who?
Wait, who?
Who is it?
Alright, let's see.
The zone token.
I'm gonna understand that.
What?
I pressed F!
Okay, let me try this again.
F.
Oh, after the game is restarted.
Okay.
I gotta restart the game, apparently.
Okay, guys, we gotta restart.
We thought we were...
We thought we got right into it, but...
We have to restart the game.
Give me a sec.
Alright.
Now!
Now we're here!
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Backup sound guy.
I choose you!
Thank you for the super chat, Johnny.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Here we go.
Now we're gaming for real, guys.
Now it's gaming hours.
Oh my gosh.
It's so weird to be streaming again.
I always, like, whenever I take a break, it's so weird to get back into streaming.
Cause it's like, how the fuck do I do all that?
How the fuck do I function as a person?
Oh yeah, but anyway.
I was...
We have to compile!
Okay, guys.
I didn't realize!
We have to compile shaders again!
It has to be faster, cause I already did it once.
It has to be faster, right?
Yeah, okay, cause we already did it.
Anyway.
The reason why I was sleeping at, like, 6 to 7 AM.
It's not just because of Overwatch.
I relapsed, by the way.
For those who don't follow me on Twitter, I have indeed relapsed back into Overwatch.
Back into the toxic relationship of Overwatch 2.
But, like, you don't understand.
He's, like, he's changed, guys.
Like, you don't understand.
He's brought back classic mode, guys.
I don't play that mode, but, like, you know, he's attempting to change.
He gave me an 8 game win streak in solo queue masters chat.
You guys don't know how rare that is.
No, I know I'm lagging cause the compiling shaders.
He told me he won't hurt me again.
It's different, guys.
It's different.
I got an 8, guys.
I got an 8 game win streak, guys.
We're not gonna talk about what happened after the 8 game win streak.
Just focus on the fact that it was an 8 game win streak.
That's all that matters, guys.
We don't talk about what happened after the 8 game win streak.
Wait, I can't change the difficulty?
Wait, what do you mean?
I don't wanna be rookie.
They're gonna make fun of me.
Like, your goons are gonna make fun of me.
And then they're like, oh, and we're gonna nominate her for gamer of the year?
Like...
Oh, I said it in.
Okay, okay.
I don't want them to make fun of me.
Oh, okay.
Looking for a balance between story.
Oh, this is beginner, beginner.
Alright, we'll do soccer.
Is it okay that I didn't play the original series?
Like, is it okay?
Freedoms always believed that a stone could bring out the best in folks, erasing the lines that...
Alright, I never wanted to read anyway.
Woah.
What's happening?
Is this Chernobyl?
Is this the radiation?
Rookie, what a weenie.
Go back to Weenie Hut Jr, Doki.
Also, Dango, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, what's that?
Is that radiation?
That's fine.
What are you gonna do?
Fucking...
Take me out?
We don't need streamer mode.
Let's listen to some fucking...
Let's listen to some songs.
Goodbye, I want no spoilers.
What the fuck are you doing?
What?
The zone?
Wait, that's what all the Dragoons kept talking about.
They're here to show support.
True, true.
They're like, we know Doki's gonna have like 20 minutes of just talking to people.
That's Dragoon right there.
He knows me.
He knows I would spend 20 or 30 minutes just chatting first.
Yeah,
if the government says everything is fine, then it should be the case, right?
Oh, wait.
Oh, wait, I'm the...
I'm holding the radiation.
Surely, right?
The government lying?
I shouldn't say that, I'm gonna fucking fall out a window.
Did you guys...
Did you guys read that?
There's been suspiciously a lot of people falling out of windows.
No, Doki!
No!
See that?
It was a hell of a blast.
Can't remember one.
So fierce.
Yeah, see, I'm okay.
It was nice knowing you.
Oh, man, that's a nice window over there.
There's another way in.
Crack in the wall to the left of the fort.
Pugger off?
Wait, am I not...
Oh, maybe he's, like, foreign.
I mean, to be fair...
I mean...
Wait, I mean, like, foreign in a foreign country.
Let's see, why is there a British man here?
A British Russian.
I don't know, I thought he was talking in more of an accent.
Well, I mean, he's talking in an accent, but, you know, not a British accent.
Like...
Don't worry, this will look good in the British Museum.
Laundry basket?
Don't lie to him!
I like how he just casually chucks it, even though it's, like, a very important artifact.
It's clearly not that important.
Yeah, that's right, nerd.
That's fucking right, nerd!
Yeah, he wants to do it again!
I was ready to see you there.
Want me to put you in the locker next?
I'm gonna stuff him in the locker.
I didn't really thought he was him.
Okay, so we gotta take this back to...
Oh my god, am I in the zone?
Is this the zone?
I'm gonna ask every time I head somewhere, I'm like, no, is this the zone?
Am I in the zone now?
Now I'm in the zone.
Okay, so...
Wait, what?
Cross the perimeter.
Okay, we're gonna head out.
What's the worst that could happen?
We're in the zone!
Oh, L.
Alright.
What's the worst that could happen?
Since we're in the zone.
I'm in the zone.
I'm locked in.
Alright, I'm reloading first, though.
Reloading first in the zone.
Guess we have to go here.
Assume there's, like, nothing I need to pick up yet.
Since it's the beginning.
Is this Chernobyl?
Ooh.
Oh, it's a little spooky.
Did I trick myself into playing a scary game?
Did I?
Oh, fuck.
Hello, I'm drinking the soda.
Whoops.
Um...
Press F, okay.
Let's see.
Tap to open and use to change your weapon.
Okay.
Guys, this looks a little spooky.
Is this supposed to be a spooky game?
Huh?
It's okay, I have a gun.
I'm not too scared.
When you have a gun, it's not as scary.
Guys, to be fair...
Comparing this to Silent Hill is, like, not even a thing.
Like...
I...
This is actually a lot less spooky than Silent Hill.
Maybe some items can be...
Okay, I have to be the knife man.
That's right.
God, how fucking strong am I?
Hello?
Knock knock.
Okay.
Grab.
Take the gun out first.
Oh, I'm in the mines.
Oh?
Oh, but...
Put down the...
Oh, I saw the sound effects.
Okay.
Put down the sound effects a little bit.
I'll put it at 85.
And then...
Alright.
I'll put that at 70 so I can raise up the volume a little bit.
Boop.
Alright, I'll put it here.
Alright, guys.
Before I continue, I actually need...
I need to get...
My cough drops.
I'll be right back real fast.
Alright.
I have to get cough drops.
Oh!
Alright.
Okay.
I'm ready.
Also, I saw some...
It's somebody else's birthday.
But I'll wish you a happy birthday very soon.
I just want to shoot one person.
Save changes.
Okay.
Can't be that bad.
Why do I need a fire?
There's nothing in front of me.
Oh!
What?
What the fuck was that?
What was that?
The fuck is that?
Hello?
Boop!
Anomies are...
Never let your guard down in the zone.
Okay.
This is my inventory.
Boop!
Oh my god.
Stop!
Wait, I won't take all of it.
How do I take all of it?
Take all.
Okay, there we go.
He seems very friendly.
Do I have...
Can I equip this?
Q, Z, E...
Okay.
Alright, now I have this gun.
Okay, so...
He doesn't...
So, he doesn't seem very...
Friendly.
So, I'm just gonna...
Do that.
What?
I had to loot so fast!
Okay, nice.
He's dead.
Oh, please don't tell me he's gonna come over.
Please don't tell me he's gonna come over.
Alright, gotta look at my iPad.
I got...
Let me...
All personnel employed by the International Perimeter must comply with the following standards outlined in the code.
Let me know...
How the...
How it is now.
Ensuring the safety and security of the perimeter.
Enter areas of anonymous activity except when required.
Alright.
A frying pan into the fire.
Return after three years of service in real hell to cool off.
Quietly trading dummies, the cheapest artifacts.
Burnt out after being taken out of the zone by some lucky stalkers.
Drinking...
Oh my god!
Name drop!
And everything seemed to be going according to plan until my flat got blown to smithereens one night.
An anomaly right in my kitchen.
It wrecked the little I had and left behind another dummy.
Only this time, it was different.
A special anomaly.
A special dummy.
And...
If a certain Herman is to be believed.
Special money I managed to recharge with a scientific gadget.
The catch is...
I'll have to venture into the zone to do it.
I've heard of enough stories to avoid the zone at all costs.
But I decided to reach out to me.
Okay.
Oh, so that's me!
I had to do this thing.
Um...
Alan, thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you, thank you!
I'm sorry I didn't use your code to buy the cup, Doki.
The shipping price was exorbitant.
Separator gives some of it to you!
Thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you, thank you!
It's okay.
I really appreciate it, guys.
For everybody that bought the gamer sub stuff.
Um...
Because, like...
You guys didn't know.
The cells determines if...
Um...
Wait, which one do I go?
Deep into the dark, scary sewers?
Or the outside?
Well, it says to go outside.
Wait, but what about spooky, dark sewers?
Oh, hey!
Ooh.
Ooh!
Ha!
Okay.
Oh, wait!
This was the same area!
I didn't see this.
Alright.
Okay, here we go.
I guess we go forward.
Main mission, the compass shows the information.
Okay.
What?
What is that?
What is that?!
What the fuck?!
Oh!
Oh, no!
No, I'm trying to...
Oh!
Oh, my God!
How many HP does he have?!
Wait.
Wait, how do I heal?
I don't remember!
I'm bleeding!
Oh, is it healed?
Okay, I'm okay.
Okay.
The fuck was that?
Like, I had zero contacts.
What the fuck was that?
Okay, hold Q.
Okay, it's fine.
I'm okay now.
I used a needle.
I used a very clean needle.
Everything is fine.
Anyway, for those who don't know, the amount of cells...
Oh, hey, vodka.
The amount of cells from the GamerSub stuff determines if I'm gonna get a flavor or not.
So, I really appreciate everybody's support!
You know, like, I didn't tweet anything yet about the GamerSub stuff.
And then, like, I think, like, in the first...
In the first, like...
What the fuck?
Apparently, in the first, like, two hours...
Wait, are they bad people?
Oh, I think they're dead.
Alright, okay.
Woah, okay.
I should've helped.
They...
We sold, like, a thousand cups in the first two hours.
I think an hour and a half?
I don't remember.
I just woke up and they were like, Woah!
You sold a thousand!
And I was like, what?
That's crazy.
Oh, I've stopped bleeding.
Guys, I don't know if you guys know this, but...
If you wait long enough, the bleeding starts to stop.
Because, like, your blood starts, like, uh...
What is it called?
Like, the scabbing?
That's what scabbing is.
Guys...
Why do I need bandages when I can just wait until it scabs up?
Guys, don't take medical advice from me.
Might not be good to wait.
Open the door.
I mean, technically, yeah.
But...
Just don't let...
Just don't touch anything bad!
If you don't touch anything bad...
Technically, you can't get an infection.
Wait, what the fuck?
Yvonne?
What happened?
What is this?
Anti-radiation drugs?
See, I told you a little radiation wouldn't hurt.
Okay...
When do I know if I'm starting...
If I'm gonna get radiated?
Hello?
Oh...
That's not a good sign.
I just, like...
I'm just gonna take everything.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, I got an artifact!
Nice.
Can open this.
So I have to go this way.
Wait, you have a gun!
Thank you.
So I have to go this way, then.
Get a double barrel ASAP.
The fuck?
Where am I gonna get a double barrel?
I just got here.
Guys, if they're dead, it's free real estate.
That's why grave robbing is legal.
I work for a British man, so, like...
He endorsed it.
Okay...
What's this?
I don't even know what I'm taking anymore.
I got his...
iPad.
I got scientific medkit.
Oh!
New lore!
I can't open the new lore, that's okay.
I didn't wanna know anyway.
Volition, as project leader, I'm ordering you to remain in the bunker until we receive the suits from the Institute.
Safety comes first.
Regardless of any side radiation coefficients you might have detected, if you venture into that cave one more time, I'll kick you out personally.
First out of the cave, then out of this project.
Got it?
Yes, it's all on my laptop.
How long will these coordinates be up to date?
Until the next emission.
So that guy of yours should move his ass.
There's someone at the bunker.
That might be the man who...
Wait!
Wait, so they were mine...
Wait, so this was recent!
They literally just died cause they saw me.
Wait, no, don't say that.
Stop freaking out and tell me where the data is stored.
Herman, calm the fuck down, Herman!
You can't say that when I'm already deep in the zone!
If you want me to do well...
Oh no...
Why did he say that when I'm in the zone already?
At least, like, lie to me.
Okay, copy data.
I mean, he can mute himself and he's gonna freak out.
Just mute yourself.
Just...
Mute yourself now.
Huh?
Oh...
Wait, no, I don't want to figure it out.
Hold my hand.
There's dead people around me, sir!
But the money's over there!
That's the whole point!
Also, Frank, I thank you for the 50...
What's that sound?
Wait, did you guys hear that?
Wait...
Wait, what'd I do?
How the fuck did they die?
What?
Okay, yeah, that would be a little...
That would be a little bit embarrassing.
Okay, so I need to find something...
So I wouldn't die...
From the entire thing.
Oh!
Oh, that's what I heard!
I fucking knew it!
I knew I heard...
I knew it!
I fucking knew I heard...
I knew I heard a...
I knew I heard this.
Oh, why is it so dark?
Is the zone always this dark?
Does it not light up in the zone?
Well...
Guys, do you guys think this is radi...
What's the worst that could happen?
Guys, do you think this is radiation?
What's the worst that could...
Don't step on those.
But what if I become Spiderman?
Guys, I could become Spiderman.
Okay, we should go this way then.
Or the...
Exactly, or the Hulk.
Guys, I could become the Hulk, guys.
I could become Red Hulk, guys.
Like I don't even see my HP anymore.
Okay, what can I do with vodka?
Or wat...
Sorry, water.
It's no easy task.
Fortunately, this isn't an issue in the mainland.
Oh, I think I'm getting irradiated.
The yellow...
Okay,
it's like here.
How do I get across then?
Oh, oh!
Oh, okay, I should...
I should stop.
I should stop getting close to that.
Who thought that that was a bat?
Is the water irradiated too?
Oh, it is.
Okay.
But it's not irradiated.
Guys, but it's yellow.
Guys, they always say follow the yellow paint.
It's actually yellow.
What if I can...
Okay, it's right here.
Freaked out that I don't see anything.
Oh...
It's fine.
A little radiation doesn't hurt anybody.
If I just like...
I just touch it a little bit...
So it can't be that bad.
Wait, what's this?
That's an anomaly.
No, no, don't eat your tuna!
Wait, how do I grab this?
That's an anomaly right there.
Guys, what is this?
How do I use my scanner?
What is that?
How come I can't get my scanner out?
Oh, get your fucking scanner out!
Am I scanning it?
Am I...
Oh, go back?
Oh, fuck.
Oh, I skipped part of the...
Oh.
Oh, sorry.
I like went to step 20.
Sorry.
Oh, shit.
I used my HP.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I'm...
I went...
I went to step 20.
Sorry.
Do I do this again?
Alright.
What do I do with this?
Do I drink the forbidden Kool-Aid?
Oh, it's right here.
Oh, I found it.
I found it.
Okay.
You want to...
You have to place them in specific...
I'm so sorry.
What the fuck is that?
Okay.
Okay, he came back.
Alright.
Okay, I...
I thought he left.
I was like...
Oh, look.
He left.
What?
What does it do?
Drop...
Your slot quickly hardens for 0.1 seconds.
Oh, my God.
No, his butt is pretty flat.
I'm not gonna lie.
What the fuck is that?
Holy fuck.
Okay.
Alright.
Now, I'm...
Now, we go this way.
Now, I can grab the other artifact.
Congratulations!
Welcome to the zone.
You're now fully certified soccer.
I have killed your first...
Your...
Oh, wait.
Nice.
Scanner.
First blood sucker.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Scan.
Yeah, the tutorial is not very intuitive.
As like a new player...
It's not as intuitive as I thought.
But...
I think like if you played the first soccer, it might be...
You might like sort of know what's going on.
Step back.
I already took damage.
Yeah, I think so.
There's like electricity all over it.
It's not?
Calm down.
Well, I can charge you the next...
Heading for the next spot.
Okay.
Okay, how the fuck was...
Okay, let me...
He said go to the next spot!
What is not an anomaly here?
Okay.
I thought...
I thought it was friendly.
Oh.
Wait, is he friendly?
Are you a friend?
Not to worry about regular people!
Guess he was not friendly.
Guess he was...
He was not friendly, guys.
He was absolutely not.
I thought we're on the same team!
You mean we're not on the same team?
Welcome to the zone, baby.
How do you have so much HP?
I don't understand!
I don't...
He was...
I don't understand.
How do you have so much HP?
Okay, one down.
No, he's not.
Am I...
Am I missing?
I'm not even...
Okay.
Okay, let me...
Am I even hitting?
Let me...
Guys, check...
Let me check my gun.
Let me...
Check my gun.
Where is he?
Did I hit him?
No.
No, no, you don't.
I lost these guns!
Please!
This is my first fight!
Alright.
Oh, that was a grenade?
Okay.
Alright.
Now, at least I can steal his stuff.
Okay, he used everything.
I literally...
That was the longest fight of his life.
He used all his fucking weapons.
Oh my god, at least he has...
Okay, thank god.
Okay, he has...
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
I'm just gonna use this gun.
This gun is a lot better.
This is a lot better.
Here's some radiation.
Don't be that bad.
Wait, there might be stuff over here.
Hello?
Oh, wait, it's floating!
Why is it floating?
Okay.
What hit me?
What the fuck is hitting me?
There's poltergeists!
What is wrong with this area?
Oh my god, please.
Please, I'm just...
Just...
I'm just trying to steal your stuff.
Wait, I don't...
I didn't save any.
Oh my god, are you fucking...
Where was the last save?
Where am I?
Wait, where was this?
Oh, this is where I killed those two men.
Do I still have their stuff?
Wait, no, I don't.
Wait, I don't have their stuff.
I guess they're dead?
I guess they despawned.
Bye now.
Okay, so there's poltergeists now.
Oh my god.
Like, what?
There's so many things.
I didn't know Chernobyl can do all that.
Hello?
What's that?
Do you think they know?
He knows, he knows!
He knew.
He...
I...
I didn't...
Didn't even...
I don't understand.
I didn't even...
I didn't even make noise.
I don't understand.
How do I do this?
Okay, now this is where you forgot to take my anti-radiation meds.
I don't understand.
I was quiet.
I was so quiet.
I'm gonna save.
Okay.
I'm just gonna run.
Alright, is the loot even good enough?
Guys?
Is it even worth it, guys?
Oh, shit.
Wrong one.
Is it?
Alright,
okay.
I'm gonna save.
Alright.
One life.
We're gonna one-life this.
Okay.
Can't chase me if I run fast enough.
Okay, guys.
I...
Okay.
Is he gonna go throw that box?
Okay, guys.
Never mind.
This is not the way.
Can't chase me if I...
Okay.
Alright.
It's okay.
We'll wait for him to throw.
Alright.
I'm climbing up.
Climbing up.
Okay, there you go.
That's right.
What you gonna do?
Fucking nothing!
Sorry.
That's what he's gonna...
I don't know.
Oh, shit!
He did something.
I didn't...
I didn't know.
I...
I didn't know!
Oh!
Okay.
We're fine.
I...
I thought he was the friendly ones!
You know?
The one where you can touch?
Oh, my God.
How do I get down from here?
Okay.
It's fine.
We did it.
We got the loot.
Wait, I can kill it?
Oh, it's over.
Oh, it's not over.
He got a fucking barrel.
Alright.
It's fine.
We'll leave.
He...
You know...
I know Casper is pissed.
Okay.
I...
I know when...
You know?
I know when, like, I should go.
I...
Like...
It's a ghost.
What is he gonna drop?
He's not gonna drop anything, guys.
It's literally a fucking ghost.
What's the point of killing him?
Okay.
I got anti-radiation drugs.
For pri...
No, I know...
You know?
I know when I'm beat.
I...
Okay.
Wait.
Let me...
Guys, I'm paranoid now.
I can't save it, because I'm too busy doing this.
Woo!
Alright.
Save.
I could've done F5, but, like...
I know this pisses you guys more.
More.
Alright.
Can't be that bad.
I did it.
Oh!
Okay.
That would've been really bad.
That would've been actually really fucking bad.
Alright.
Nice.
I took it.
I feel like everything is an anomaly at this point.
Like, what is an anomaly?
Like, do I have anything that's not an anomaly?
Guys, you can't just say...
You can't say, like, anything you see is an anomaly.
The more damage you take...
But what's the radiation part?
Guys, a little radiation doesn't hurt.
See?
If I run past it, it should be fine.
Wait, somebody died here.
Another person died here.
But how do I treat this?
Guys, what do I press to treat my radiation issue?
There's so many now.
What is an anomaly?
I feel like everything...
If everything is an anomaly, then nothing...
Then everything is considered normal at this point.
Time will heal.
It's alright.
People see sparks all the time.
Time will heal itself, right?
Wait, does vodka heal...
Does it actually?
Oh my god, I fucking knew it.
Just keep drinking.
I knew my doctors were wrong.
I knew my therapist was wrong when she said it's...
When she said I should stop.
Okay, obviously.
How do I get through this?
The window over here.
It's technically water if you think about it.
Okay, let's grab...
Some ammo, some bandages.
Oh, more vodka.
More medicine.
I think I see anomaly.
There's this really cute blonde girl on the right.
Thank you for the super chat, Kensei.
Thank you, thank you.
At this point, everything is anomaly.
If everything is anomaly, then everything is normal.
Wait, here?
That's the water.
It's like here.
It's like right here?
Oh no, I feel like I should not touch the water.
Oh, wait.
Wait a minute.
Oh, wait a minute.
Maybe I can come...
Oh, thank God.
Okay, I can go back up.
Okay.
I thought I fucked up a little bit, but that's okay.
Never punished.
But where...
Where is it?
Oh, it's literally right here.
I did not see this.
Such is the life in the zone.
Airborne, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, nice.
We did it.
Should be the last one.
Well, cutscene me is a lot smarter.
Nice.
Can I scan everything?
Oh.
Aren't they ever tired of just fucking calling everything an anomaly?
I'm fucking tired.
Anomaly this, anomaly that.
When is it...
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck.
Is that anomaly?
Is that also an anomaly?
Boy, it's anomaly.
He sold us out?
I can't believe the guy I just met betrayed me.
Hello?
Are you anomaly?
Are they?
Are they anomaly?
Are they anomalies?
Maybe the anomalies are just the friends we made along the way.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, shit!
Guys, it only took me 40 minutes to finish the tutorial.
It only...
I did it.
Are you anomaly?
That has to be anomaly.
No!
Don't shoot the guy!
He's just trying...
He's just trying to give a good lick.
Oh, shit!
Oh!
Richard.
What?
What's this?
Yeah, why would I need a ball?
That happened to my dog once.
What?
Tosses to anomaly?
Why do they hate balls?
Determine its boundaries and even temp...
Use tab and select the ball.
Okay.
Okay,
I neutralized it.
I'm sorry!
Guys, I did not neutralize it.
Guys, I did...
I did not neutralize.
What?
Okay.
Oh, my God!
You mean it's timed?
I thought...
Oh, I thought it was...
I didn't realize...
I didn't realize it's timed.
I was like...
Okay, I'm just gonna...
Okay.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
That's right.
First try.
Guys, it was first try, guys.
It was first try.
Molly, thank you for the super chat.
See, he knew I could do it, guys.
He believed in me.
I was attacked.
He knows nothing but my birthday suit.
The bartender?
Why is...
What?
Why is a bartender still living in the zone?
What kind of money will you...
What?
Move!
Just move!
Is he...
Who's not an anomaly at this point?
I should be allowed to grab a sign.
Wait, there's some vodka.
Okay.
Wait, there's loot.
Okay, there's no loot.
Wait, oh no, I was here.
What?
I'm not special?
Yeah, who are you?
Who are you?
You took tour guides for zones?
Oh my god.
He's a stalker.
Get away from him, he's a stalker!
He's gonna dox you!
They tried to resist, but...
Caution of put them in their place quick enough.
He made sure they wouldn't mess with the new world order.
Anyway, stay away from the ward.
And don't mention this around them, obviously.
Oh yeah, they're like, stay away from them!
And then...
And then, and then like you're like...
I'm gonna do it!
It's always like that.
Stay away from him.
JK!
That means I should get close.
Okay, yeah, why are you helping me?
Or am I somehow special?
To quote my fictional dad...
Son, help if you can.
And if you can, don't get in the way.
So, don't get in the way.
Or help if you will.
My men at the post office need a hand.
Bring them a couple of medkits.
You'll be able to make some friends, maybe.
Make some friends!
Okay, we gotta go to meet...
Go to the bar.
Guys, we're gonna make some friends.
We're totally not gonna try and kill me.
Nice.
Okay, gotta get all of this.
I wish there was an easier way to take all the loot.
I don't wanna like right click.
I just wanna take all...
I'm pretty sure there is and you guys are just gonna...
Okay, so there's that.
Open the map.
What's the map say?
What the fuck?
Wait, what's this?
What is this?
Okay, uh...
What's that question mark?
Information about all active.
Use Q and E to navigate the PDA.
Okay.
What is this?
What's the question mark?
Oh my...
And there is a fog too?
This is me.
And this is the rest of the world.
Welcome to the zone.
I'm in the lesser zone because I'm lesser I guess.
What's the question mark?
Yeah, I heard this is an open world.
That's a little me.
Alright, do you think there's bus...
Do you think there's actually a bus stop?
Are you guys good people?
Hey guys.
Oh, he's not good.
He's not a good person.
Oh, is he gonna do run after me?
Hello?
How is there fighting?
I'm nothing!
Oh, I'm gonna leave.
Fuck this.
You can handle this yourself.
What do you mean?
What?
Oh.
Gun.
I was like, what gun?
There you go.
Gun.
Alright, gun down.
Okay, we got gun.
Okay, I didn't realize I had a gun.
I thought they took everything.
Woah!
I thought they took everything!
Oh, I'm still reloading!
Okay.
One down.
I'm trying to headshot!
How?
What armor are you wearing?
What is this armor that you have?
Okay.
At least I have a shotgun now.
Okay, I want to loot...
Where are the other bodies that I killed?
Oh, there it is.
Okay, he has so much ammo.
So good.
Okay.
He had two shotguns.
I have nades.
I wonder if there's like an...
Oh, wait, is that?
Wait, what gun is this?
Okay.
Thank God.
Wait!
They can...
There's durability?!
God fucking...
Okay.
Oh, R is take- Oh, thank God.
Alright.
Thank God!
Now I can...
Now I can look less stupid.
Yay!
My dragoons can stop making fun of me.
Why are they trying to shoot anyway?
Oh yeah, we should save.
Is it F5?
Yeah, I saved it.
They're here.
Man, I wish I could read that.
Oh!
This is safe water.
Finally!
This is not safe water.
This is...
This is not...
Wait, there was a dude there?!
It's fine.
I have vodka.
I didn't even see the guy in there.
Is there a guy here?
Oh, guys.
I'm not...
I'm feeling a little...
I'm feeling a little weird.
Toki, that sign says danger.
God, I knew you said I wish I could read.
How was I supposed to know?
Does it look like I can read?
I can barely read English!
Where's the guy I saved?
Where...
Oh wait, no.
They shot him here.
I forgot it was right here.
Oh, there you are.
Hello.
Answer.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Not all triangles are dangerous!
Richard sent me.
I used a little bit of the medkits, though.
Sure, I do.
He came here with Squint, our leader.
He used to be a guide, so he knows the area.
And like any guide, he's got your back on the road, but...
Don't count on him jumping into a firefight with you.
Best you can hope for is he sends some help your way.
I might be pushing my luck here, but...
Could you lend me a hand with something else?
Wait, what?
Oh, a mission!
What are you doing here anyway?
Yeah, what are you doing here anyway?
Yeah, why are you here?
I could ask you the same thing, but I won't.
The less we know about each other, the better.
Lose lips and all that, you know?
Wait, but you want me to help you.
Alright, let's hear it.
There's four of us at the boiler house, not far from here.
I like how, like...
Because we're playing this in English...
Instead of them having, like, Ukrainian accents...
They have, like, Scottish-slash-English accents!
What is this?
Like, are we in, like, fucking the UK now?
Are we, like, in the United Kingdom?
Alright, fine.
Wait, how many are there, though?
The zone expanded to all of Europe!
The UK is an anomaly!
Alright, I'll do it.
I mean, it doesn't mean I have to.
It just shows up.
I'll say yes just to make him feel better.
And then, like, his friends will be like...
His friends will be like, hey, so that guy you sent...
Like, is he coming?
Yeah, and then he'll be like, yeah!
Like, I sent him, like, three weeks ago.
Alright, nice.
I don't have to do this mission.
Okay, maybe I should drink some vodka.
I don't like... I don't like just seeing this.
Alright, there we go.
Wait, is that not vodka?
No, it's water!
Okay, maybe beer?
Does beer help it?
Okay, alcohol.
Okay, it's always alcohol.
Alright, let's loot this area.
There might be some loot here.
Is there loot anywhere?
Anywhere?
No!
Water!
Not water!
Anything but water.
They might give you free loot.
Yeah, but then I'm gonna... I might have to lose some of my loot to save them.
Is there a door?
Beer o'clock!
The fuck is the door?
Oh, it's over here.
Okay.
Hello?
Is there anything?
Anything?
Any free stuff?
Oh, nice.
Oh, R.
I learned.
It's R.
Beer carries everything.
Oh, I mean, it's like a hundred...
Okay, so it's next door.
It's not that bad, actually.
It is next door.
It's not that bad.
Guys, but it has triangle.
You guys said triangle is dangerous.
Hello?
I'm here.
What's that sound?
Are you an anomaly?
Ah!
Okay.
I see him.
He has to peek.
No, you're here.
Oh!
This is not fair!
I have a pistol!
Oh my God!
Get out!
They can do that?!
He just...
He just walked out!
That's illegal!
That's actually illegal!
Holy fuck!
That's illegal!
Oh!
I'm gonna run up.
Where is he?
What the fuck?
He ran over here now?!
Where is he?
That was literally...
I don't have ammo for this anymore!
I need to reload.
Reload!
There we go.
Jesus Christ!
Oh, powerful!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Where's the last guy?
I can't believe it!
He just...
Oh, you think...
Oh, you think that's gonna save you?
Oh wait, it is.
I don't know where...
Whoa!
Give me a sec.
Reloading.
That's fucking right.
There we go.
Everything is fine now.
That...
That took way too long.
It took...
Oh no, I gotta use a bandage.
Wait, there's more?!
More left?
No, it's night time!
Please!
Where are you?
Where did he come from?
Oh, I'm fucking turning on the lights.
Okay.
At least I have two bullets.
Where is he?
Oh shit!
What?!
Oh fuck!
AD!
There we go!
I knew it!
The cat AD!
My AD!
Alright.
Nice, we did it.
Movement!
I fucking movement!
Alright, nice.
Wait, oh wait, he's...
There.
Oh wait, I'm bleeding.
Sir, I'm bleeding.
Sir, I'm bleeding, please.
Sir, can you talk a little faster?
Yeah.
Yeah?
Sir, I'm bleeding, please.
I'm not okay.
I'm bleeding.
That detector will do?
We got time to bleed.
Here you go, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Welcome.
I mean...
Okay.
You know...
What?
I thought he was talking about me.
Okay, I have attachments?
I don't have attachments.
Wait, so what were you doing here, Gloomy?
Yeah, you allowed him in there.
So what's the point of living in the zone?
Oh, thanks for asking.
Oh, Gloomy's watching my stream.
Thanks, Gloomy.
I didn't realize you were watching the stream.
Alright, so...
Okay, I should reload this.
Alright.
So apparently it's better than living in the mainland.
Wait, if I change it to, like, Ukrainian...
Do they speak English Ukrainian?
Like, English in a Ukrainian accent?
Or, like, Ukrainian?
And it's like, put it in Ukrainian.
But I'm like, no, guys.
There's a reason why I didn't put it in...
Okay, no.
I think it's, like, full Ukrainian.
Guys, okay.
I don't think...
Guys,
I don't think I can understand what he's saying.
You can read.
It'll be fine.
Guys, I rather think that UK means the United Kingdom.
When they say UK, they mean the United Kingdom.
Did I get everything?
Oh, no, I didn't.
I feel like I have, like, so much, like, random junk.
Okay.
We did it.
We finished.
Okay, and then I guess, like, we can go to the actual...
Do we need to go back to the other guy?
If only Doki could read.
The UK Brexit, they did it so hard.
They went to Chernobyl.
I just find it fucking hilarious that, like, you would think they would have Ukrainian accents, you know?
But then, like, but instead, it's, like, they give them British accents.
So, it's, like, it's so weird.
Bonsai, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
It was your birthday?
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Bonsai.
United Chernobyl.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Then we go this way.
See, guys?
I'm learning.
Who said I can't learn?
Can I, like, go from here?
Oh, no.
I don't think I was supposed to go here.
Wait a minute.
Wait.
This doesn't make sense.
How do I cross it?
I don't think I was supposed to go there.
Like here, maybe?
Oh, I'm sorry!
Okay, it wasn't there.
Wait, I fucked it up.
Wait, now I'm stuck here.
Okay, there we go.
The fuck?
Okay.
Oh, I have to go here.
I have to.
I hate this.
I hate this map system.
I'm trying to figure out how to fucking traverse here.
Get me out of here.
Maybe here?
What's that?
What's that over here?
Oh, nice.
Is there any options to have Ukrainian voice actors and English subs?
Excuse me, this is so funny.
Either way, Jesus Christ.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The only issue is like I gotta read.
Oh, strangers with guns aren't welcome to hide your weapon.
Use H.
Oh, I'm friendly!
Where's the strangers with guns?
I'm friendly.
I don't have guns.
I don't have a gun in my hand.
I'm friendly.
Hello!
Hey!
Yo, it's you around the zone.
Alright.
Thanks, NPC.
Mr. Kyle number 4.
So, what happens if I...
What happens if I...
Wait, he's friendly.
Yeah.
He doesn't care if I have a gun.
The fuck did I hide my gun?
Okay.
Hey, so why are you in the zone?
Bye!
Yeah, how do you?
Okay.
A good soldier follows orders.
Oh, shit.
There are dogs in the military.
See, there's nothing to worry about.
They're friendly.
Okay, we gotta meet the Zen... Zendaya.
I don't remember her name.
I assume it's Zendaya.
It's like over here.
Are you guys having a good time?
Eh.
Join stalkers for some gossip.
The fuck?
There you go.
I'm gonna get copyright strike for all around the world.
Miss Worldwide.
I'm gonna be like, whoa.
Zendaya, is that you?
Oh, soldier?
It's alright.
We're gonna risk it.
We don't need ad revenue for the 70th time.
I think like 20% of my channel is like demonetized.
That's like, fuck streamer mode!
Three dead wardens up the zone's ass.
A good start.
Oh!
For me?
A trader who goes by Hamster is peddling this service weapon.
Belonged to one of those wardens.
He got it from Squint.
Apologies, Captain.
But Zalesia is a free trade zone.
We have an agreement with Caution.
Where is Squint?
The zone has its share of secrets.
Who are we to meddle in its designs?
Playing a wise and stalker sage, are you?
Fine.
Guys, so you know how this is like my first stalker game?
What the fuck is a stalker game?
Because I feel like I should ask that now.
They never explained it!
They never explained what a stalker is!
Oh shit!
No, I'm stalking the J!
No!
I...
I... No!
Oh, okay.
Oh, thank god.
Okay, I was like, what did I say?
What did I say?
Oh, so I break in the fine artifacts.
Okay.
So I'm illegal.
What the fuck is this?
I thought he would wait for me.
That's me.
Now I know what it means.
Oh, illegal treasure hunter.
Oh my god, it is the UK!
I thought it would be for Ukraine, but it's actually for the United Kingdom!
I'm basically Indiana Jones!
The zone belongs in a museum!
Who should I ask about the solder yet?
I'm gonna move the entire zone to the UK!
I didn't know Chernobyl was located in London, guys.
I gotta find a solder and beat the shit out of him for selling us out.
Okay.
So you have any jobs for me?
It's actually in Birmingham, Tokyo!
I need my money back.
Who's Valek Lomax?
The man is this Valek Lomax guy.
He's new to the zone, but he already made a name for himself.
This one sharp asshole.
Not afraid of risks.
Always full of white plants.
Kinda liked the guy.
Thought he would go far.
He went too far.
Got himself a new gun.
I'm still mopping about how to set him straight.
Okay.
Yeah, sure.
I can do it.
My money.
Alright.
No problem, warlock.
I got you.
I'm good at beating muscle.
Doesn't require a brain for that.
I'm gonna steal some vodka.
Vodka.
Real quick.
Hello.
You seem like...
Oh.
Okay, nevermind.
Hi!
Oh,
cool.
Oh, so it's like...
Oh, wait.
No free stuff.
Oh, beer.
Beer is so expensive these days.
So it's like you gotta fight yourself.
Oh, personal note.
iPad.
I've chosen not to speak openly about his.
But hear me out.
I've had enough.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Why can't all messages be like this?
Oh, this is what happened.
Okay.
Let's see.
I have to ask warlock.
Okay.
And ask gafter.
Ask captain.
Okay, so I need to find everything I need to find out about soldier.
Alright.
Open.
Which one?
Me?
Not me?
Okay, we gotta go this way.
Okay, where is...
Is it here?
Hello.
The game is based on a movie.
Which that movie is based on a book.
Called Roadside Picnic.
Where in the book, aliens arrived on earth to have a picnic.
And leaving the trash.
And aliens trashed another person's treasure.
Thank you for the super chat, Giga.
Thank you, thank you.
That makes a lot more sense now.
I'm allowed to walk past this?
How do you know I'm a stalker?
I'm just wearing regular clothes.
Okay, what do you need?
Okay, but everybody is a piece of shit here.
Isn't that what the zone is?
You gotta be a piece of shit to be here.
Okay.
Screw me.
Yay,
murder!
Who's Uncle Leona?
Oh, it's Squint!
Wait, me?
Yeah!
I'm just a guy with five bullets!
Wait, can you at least give me some bullets?
Wait, I have five bullets!
Like, if you want me to do this...
I have five bullets!
Please, sir!
Look at my- oh wait, what the fuck is this?
Okay, JK.
JK, I don't just have five bullets.
JK, but he doesn't know that.
He doesn't know that, though.
JK.
Okay, I'm still looking.
That's my report.
Alright.
I did my job.
Can I load anything here?
Make sure to unload.
Sometimes, they have bullets in the magazine.
I can unload a gun?
I mean, yeah, but like...
In a video game?
Do I have, like...
More bullets for this?
I do.
Okay.
Okay, that should be...
Good, right?
Okay.
Oh, G is to unload?
I need to, like...
Sell these.
Maybe if I take this, and then...
Okay, it's unloaded already.
So...
I'm gonna double check...
My guns.
Okay, we'll unload this.
G, right?
Guys, you lied to me.
Wait a minute.
Can't unload a gun?
Can't unload it?
I need to sell these, though.
Sell these, and then...
This, and...
You right-click, and it'll unload...
Oh!
Wait, why did I unload this?
This is the best one I have.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, let's see.
Wait, do I have lots of ammo?
Oh my god, I have so many ammos!
Wait, this is...
Actually pretty neat.
Okay, we'll take this out, and then...
Unload these, and...
Okay, we're keeping that.
And then we'll sell all the other guns.
Okay, nice.
Okay, where is...
Repeat a map.
Where am I?
Warlock...
Bar...
Oh, there's Zendaya!
Um...
Hamster, trader, private box...
Guide...
Okay, we gotta go...
We gotta go to...
Oh, there's a side activity.
We gotta go to a trade...
Oh, I gotta go to the medic.
Wait, I need to get healed.
Is this where the...
Is this where the medic is?
The actress?
Where the fuck is he?
How do I go to the medbay?
Are you the healer?
Who's your boss?
I don't fucking know who your boss is!
Hello?
Are you the boss?
That's so...
That's what I'm saying!
If, like, everything's a fucking anomaly...
Then, like...
What's real?
That's what I'm fucking saying!
Read the five print.
We're selling this.
Wait, how do I sell it?
Um...
How do I sell it?
Take it!
Fucking take my...
He won't...
Oh, you're so fucking...
Nobody likes you.
Oh, he's a random?
He has a name.
Guys, he has a name.
He's not just some random NPC.
Yeah, patch me up, please.
No, I meant, like, mentally.
Okay, maybe on the outside.
You're a doctor.
You should know I am not okay.
You should know.
Okay.
Okay, Peter Matt.
Wait, then where is the trader?
Okay, I guess we have to go this way.
There's a trader here.
Alright, we gotta get to the trader.
Are you a trader?
What's your name?
Does he be here?
Oh my god, this area is so confusing.
A little.
Where's the trader?
Is it Hamster in here?
Wait, is that that guy?
The bartender?
Oh, it's him!
The warlock.
Okay, how do I... okay, trade.
Okay, take my shit.
Take it!
What do you mean?
Oh, okay, he takes that.
Okay, he doesn't take these.
Okay.
Okay, I guess I can sell this then.
Oh, it can't be sold?
Okay, at least I get a thousand and five dollars.
Which is like ten American, I think.
There's other traders that will pay more?
That's fine.
I don't need that.
Oh, don't?
Whoop, too late.
Wait, did I fuck up?
Hey, can I buy my gun back?
Are you serious?
Are you...
How much money do I have?
I don't...
But I sold you three guns!
I sold you three guns!
Another loss to the zone.
I got it.
Also, guys, I can't.
If I reload a save, I wouldn't have learned anything.
So that's why everybody was yelling.
Plenty more guns.
So that's why everybody was yelling at me.
Hello, Lance.
That must have been an anomaly.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
He has to be an anomaly.
Yeah, do you have any work for me?
A bunch of diggers who used to bring me all sorts of useful stuff have gone off the radar.
I'm feeling a little uneasy about it.
Wait, I'll do it.
Don't have to save money anymore.
I need $3,000.
I have the coordinates for their last outing.
I told them to stay away from that tunnel.
Back Saturday, Bedlam.
Alright.
I'm desperate.
I'm very desperate right now.
Oh, wait, upgrade?
How much is an upgrade?
Oh, I can upgrade, like, my stuff here.
I can repair.
Okay.
I mean, that's good to know.
Okay, I need to find...
I need to find the other guy for this.
Okay, 221.
Wait, where am I heading?
Oh, okay.
I can meet this guy.
So he should be here.
I'm so directionally challenged.
He's in this house.
He has to be in this house.
Oh, he's playing the guitar!
Guitar!
Yes!
Well, not really.
I'm just getting involved.
Oh, it's Richie!
Wait, I wanna ask about Soldier.
Yeah.
Sorry for almost getting you killed.
Where?
Wait, we are trying to find Squid.
What has he done?
Oh yeah, I saw that!
I was like wondering what it was.
Okay.
Sure.
Oh yeah, I know where he is!
I know where Squid is!
Well, like, asking people is not...
You just gotta ask.
It's like those people who are like, just ask directions and you're like, NO!
Wait, is Squid part of his team?
I thought he was a bad guy.
Oh my god, is this like Fallout where I have to join factions?
Wait.
Do I have to like, decide which faction I wanna be in?
Oh shit!
Okay.
I don't know, I feel like the word people seem to have their shit together.
Like, you might say they did save me earlier, but like...
Okay, we gotta go here.
Explore the warehouse with radiation.
This is the...
This has to be the Squid thing.
Okay, Uncle Leona.
Maybe he'll guide me there.
I mean, the word seems to be like...
They seem to pay a lot more, too.
They really love the big rock?
Wait, I love rocks!
We already have so much in common!
We are...
Alright, we go this way.
Wait, maybe the Leona guy can guide me there.
Okay, I was gonna say this tiny ass thing, I can't even go through that.
Wait, where's the guide?
Where's Uncle Leona?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, okay.
Thanks for all the help, I guess.
Oh, that's it?
You're just gonna be like, you got this.
You're literally a guide!
Guide people!
Alright.
I guess we... Alright, we'll do the...
Yay!
Okay, I just need to figure out what to do first.
Okay.
We'll do the...
How am I bleeding?
What did I do?
Did I trip?
Did I...
What happened?
Did I fucking, like, stub my toe?
There was a barbed wire?
I'm gonna stub my toe.
There we go.
Okay, we'll go do the mini mission first, because it's, like, literally right here.
Okay, I already have my light on.
I wasn't sure.
This area is so dark.
Alright.
The grass, it was the anomaly.
Bleeding is an anomaly.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, we'll explore here first.
Can't be that bad.
What happened?
Shoot first, ask questions later.
Don't worry, movement.
Alright.
Oh, shit!
I saw the present.
Alright, that should be it.
See?
Easy.
Look at that, guys!
I'm figuring out how to aim in this game!
Oh my god, it's a fucking nerd.
Okay.
Yeah, pay him what you owe him!
Pay up your debt to Warlock first.
He promised me a cut.
Ah, well...
I was going to pay him back, honest.
Now?
Fair enough, that's the right thing to do.
Done.
I sent the coupons.
Both yours and Warlock's.
Coupons?
What?
They just got crypto?
Is that...
Did I got crypto?
What the fuck is coupons?
Did he just send me crypto?
Like, cryptocurrency?
I thought I'd get, like, cash.
Wait, what happens if I kill him?
Would anything bad happen to me?
Like, I already got what I needed.
He died.
I don't know.
I lose trust.
Who's gonna see it?
If I close all the doors, no one will know it was me.
No one will know.
He didn't even react.
Guys, I didn't...
Guys, he didn't even react.
I didn't realize I was doing damage.
I didn't know how he got him.
I didn't know.
I thought...
I thought I did zero damage.
When I get found...
When the flashes...
Each particle continues to...
He trusted you, Doki.
He fucking just...
I don't know.
He collapsed.
I was supposed to know it worked.
You pumped him twice.
You pumped him twice on his shoulder.
He fell dead.
Truly...
I was a fucking nerd.
I knew he was a nerd.
Guys, it wasn't me.
He got a heart attack, chat.
He got a heart attack.
It wasn't me.
I thought it didn't even do damage.
I just let it go.
It doesn't even work.
You liars.
You can't even kill him.
He just fell over.
He just fell out.
He just fell out of the window, guys.
Whoa.
Guys, the window got him.
It wasn't me.
Here we go.
Oh, it's this way.
Okay.
I can't...
I don't have a detector, though.
I'm pretty sure.
I guess there should be an artifact here.
Did I get a scan?
Oh, I did.
I did.
Yeah, but I don't think I can...
There's anything in here.
Okay, yeah.
That was a mistake.
Oh, I got bread, though.
It's okay.
I got bread.
Alright.
Never mind.
That did nothing.
The artifact saved me?
Did I lose my artifact?
Did I lose it?
No, I still have it.
Okay.
I got the good... See?
Guys, look at that.
If I didn't beat up that nerd, I would have died.
See?
I live because I beat up a nerd.
His life for mine.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, Squint is here.
I hear him.
He's playing guitar.
He can't be a bad person.
Hello?
Hey.
I'm looking for a stalker.
Where did he go?
Oh,
this is difficult.
This is difficult.
You know what?
I'm tired.
That's right!
What's he gonna do?
Play the guitar?
Oh, shit!
Okay.
I have to reload this gun.
Wait, what?
Wait, what?!
There's so many dogs!
Okay, reload.
How many dogs do they have?!
We're not, we're not, we're okay.
They don't know how to walk over.
No!
Wait, I have to jump up?
Okay, wait.
Actually, I'm curious.
Can he actually go up?
Wait, I have to jump up?
No!
I don't like the sound they make!
I don't like it!
What the fuck?!
Okay, no.
Fuck you, actually.
There we go.
Stop!
Stop eating the bread!
Okay.
Okay, we're fine.
That should be all the dogs.
Okay, nevermind.
That should, now that should be all the dogs.
Oh my god.
God, please, I need to stop eating the bread.
I need...
How do I re...
Okay, quick access.
How do I quick access?
No, no, not you!
Stop!
How do I...
Oh my god.
I'm stressed eating.
I'm so stressed out.
I keep eating bread.
Wait,
where's that one guy?
Did he die?
Did I kill him?
Yeah, you found me?
Nice.
I'm gonna go in.
I'm gonna run in.
It's gonna be a drive-by.
Wait, where did he go?
I told you.
Is that it?
Loot that body.
Told you it was gonna be a drive-by.
Alright, nice, I did it.
Where did...
Where did all these dogs come from?
Holy shit.
Where did they keep...
They keep all those dogs.
Oh, that's not good.
I gotta drink some vodka.
Beer.
Am I okay now?
Okay, I can drag this here.
Wait, no I can't.
How do I...
Oh, it's he...
Oh my god, I'm so stupid.
I'm so stupid.
Alright, unload my guns.
Alright, we're gonna...
Unload.
Okay, we should have...
Is everything unloaded?
Unload.
Nice, okay, everything is unloaded.
And then we'll reload this.
Oh, there's more boomstick.
Means that... Oh, okay, I should get rid of some guns.
Okay.
Alright, we'll drop this.
Drop all.
Wait, is it better than the one I have?
Are they different?
Wait, they're different?
Wait.
Are they different?
No, they're not.
Wait, they are?
Oh, shit.
Oh, only the durability.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I should replace...
Okay, they're all shit.
They're all like fucked up.
But why does it say 2 and 3?
Oh, I guess like this has more durability.
Oh!
Okay, I'm learning.
Oh, I see.
Same durability stacks.
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, that makes more sense.
I can have a suppressor.
I didn't notice I have a suppressor.
This is like Fallout.
Wait, this game is basically like Fallout.
Okay, I did this.
Okay, we gotta go here then.
It's not?
Wait, how would you compare this game...
...to...
...Fallout?
If it was good!
I guess it's like Metro, but open world.
Yeah, I can see that.
Yeah.
I can see this is like...
...Metro with like...
...open world stuff.
Okay, I'm retired.
My stamina is not as good as it used to be.
Okay, it's over there.
Alright.
Alright, let's reload...
...and then head over.
Can't be that hard to kill.
Why would I need to eat food in this game?
Like, what is the...
Do I even have like a food meter?
Hello?
Wait, am I hungry?
It's hard to tell...
...because I don't have like a food meter.
Is that where I am?
Is that what the chicken is?
Oh my god, I'm hungry!
I didn't realize!
Oh my god, it's gone!
Oh my god, I was hungry!
It's gone now!
Okay, let's...
I guess I'll drop this...
...since I'm...
I didn't know!
Okay.
Let's see, we got more stuff.
Hello?
Wait.
There's a lot of dead people here.
Why is there a lot of dead people here?
Squint!
What are you doing down in the mines?
Oh, not the mines.
Why did you take me to the mines?
You fucking fool.
Dogs.
There's mean dogs.
There's evil dogs.
Wait, where?
Where are the dogs?
Hello?
Oh my god.
How the fuck am I gonna get to...
How?!
Okay.
Alright, I actually do have to thread the needle.
Oh, this is scary.
Okay, we made it.
Okay.
How the fuck was he able to make it all the way here?
Alright, nice.
Wait, there he is.
Alright, dog down.
Oh, oh, wait.
Oh wait, they're fighting each other.
Oh, they're fighting the dogs.
Okay.
Wait, isn't this where I came from?
Oh no, this is the death creator.
That's good, they're fighting the dogs.
I don't have to worry about them.
If I shoot them here, will they come over?
Guys, they're coming over.
It's okay, the dogs got him.
Oh, shit!
Okay!
Dogs!
Oh, shit!
Is he an evil man?
Are they good people?
Oh, they're good people, they're good people.
They're friendly.
Hello!
Oh, shit.
Oh, shit!
There's friendly fire!
Nobody told me there's friendly fire!
Alright, we gotta...
Yeah, we gotta do our radiation stuff.
Radiation check.
Uh...
What is...
Okay, we gotta put it in the beer category.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Who are you?
Hello.
Are there other stalkers?
Bro, they fucking...
What do you mean?
He fucking...
He shot first!
Okay, where is...
Where is he?
Where's Squint?
Might be hiding.
I swear, I like, looked everywhere.
Am I missing something?
Where could he be hiding?
Where are you hiding?
Oh, you think you can get away from me, don't you?
Oh, you think you can get away from me, Squint?
This is where I went down.
Is he actually still in the attic?
Maybe I didn't look properly.
I mean, it is like the mines.
Maybe he's actually still in here.
I don't know if I like, searched it properly.
Oh, sorry, attic is up.
Whoops.
Well, I can't go back down.
I can't go back up.
Up is down.
I don't know if you guys know that.
But up...
I gotta do this stupid thing all over again.
God damn it.
I have to do this all over again.
Whoops.
Alright, it's fine.
I mastered it.
Welcome to the zone, Doki.
Thank you for your very first super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, up is down.
Guys, let me find Squint first.
I gotta find Squint.
Wait, who's fighting again?
Wait, what?
What's going on?
I just got here.
Let me do that.
I'm trying to find...
What's going on?
Squint.
Squint, where are you hiding?
Where the fuck are you hiding?
Okay, still the good people.
Oh, free loot.
Nice.
Why have I not looted yet?
I can't tell, guys.
They all look the same.
Everything looks the same, guys.
I can't tell what I haven't looted yet.
Oh, shit!
I thought they were the same helpful people!
Oh my god, please.
I'm still trying to find Squint.
Please, where is he?
Is he in the...
Oh my god, I swear to god.
If he was in the windmill this entire time...
I swear to fucking god.
Wait, the friendly stalkers are dead?
Okay, we just go to the windmill.
Alright, we got...
Okay, I think they're in the windmill.
I think he's in the windmill.
I think he's hiding in there.
Alright, let's drop...
Drop bad things.
Unload...
Oh wait, that's a better gun.
Drop...
There we go.
And then we gotta...
Gotta drink.
Drink our vodka.
I know you're in here.
I know you're in here, Squint.
Woah!
I fucking knew it.
Oh, I'm coming over, Squint.
I'm coming over.
I don't know where you are, but I'm coming over.
Oh, you thought you got me this time?
Squint, where are you, Squint?
Oh, Squint!
That's fucking right, you nerd.
That's right.
Where's the window?
Oh no!
He fell down the window!
Oh no, yes!
He said I could kill him!
He said it was fine to kill him!
Oh no!
Window, no!
He fell down the window!
After 20 bullets.
Wow, that was just...
It was totally blameless.
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, that's so unfortunate!
Oh my god, I can't believe the window got him!
Oh my god!
Because I wanted to be in the ward faction anyway, guys.
I guess I'm a ward now.
I mean, ward is not too bad.
They seem cool.
People just happen to fall from the window a lot!
I can't believe he dropped his gun and it shot him in the face.
Guys, he tripped and it triggered the gun.
Like, can you really blame me?
We got...
We did it!
We got the censors!
Guys, we did it!
Guys, we're truly in Eastern Europe now.
We're in EU!
Look, all I'm saying is he did shot first.
We're going by...
Whoa.
Bad.
Bad anomaly.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
This looks like a lot of bad anomalies.
How the fuck do I get home?
Okay, I don't know if this is the right time to just sit there.
But like, okay.
Guys, he shot first.
Guys.
How do I get home?
Okay, we go down and then left.
Okay.
Whoa!
Bad anomaly!
Bad!
Oh my God!
Wait, where's my last save?
Where's my last save?
Where'd it go?
Oh, where did I go?
Where did I go?
Oh shit, again.
Oh shit.
Alright, we gotta do this again.
Oh man, it's...
It's so unfortunate that he fell from the window.
Whoa!
Oh my God!
But it's okay.
He was...
He was alive, but then he tripped and fell from the window again!
Oh shit, wait, wait.
Then he tripped and then he...
He fell from the window again.
Oh my God, that is so unfortunate.
That is so...
I can't believe it.
He was so clumsy!
It was so...
It was so tragic.
It really was.
It really was incredibly tragic.
Oh man, I wish I was there to stop it.
That's so sad.
I'm so sad.
I could do nothing to stop it.
It's so unfortunate.
And then, like, the windmill burned down too after.
Like, wow, so unfortunate.
Gone.
Such is the life in the zone.
Yep.
Just another day in the zone.
Nothing could have prevented this.
Exactly!
Like, nothing could have prevented it, guys.
It was simply life in the zone.
Oh my God, I'm like a little paranoid right now.
I'm a little crazy.
What is that sound?
This is how I died last time.
Wait, that's it?
Wait, isn't that how I died last time?
Wait, that is how I died last time.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, how do I get home?
I'm always lost.
Like, which way?
Okay, it's this way.
Oh my God, there's so many weird anomalies.
Like, I can't go anywhere here.
Oh, there's a bridge.
Be gone!
Oh.
Wait, there's an artifact here.
Not again!
Oh.
I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry.
I'm on the road now.
I'm on the road.
I survived.
Nothing can hurt me.
Nothing.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
I've run.
Alright, we're fine.
We're fine.
Follow the road.
Wait, where did home go?
Wait.
Oh, it's right in front of me.
Okay.
It's right in front of me.
Oh, I hate.
I hate this.
I hate this so much.
Oh, I hate this.
I hate this.
If I keep throwing it, nothing...
They can't get me if I keep throwing this.
They can't get me.
Oh, I'm here.
I'm here now.
I did it, Warden.
I did it, Wards.
I killed him.
I mean, he fell from the window.
Sorry.
It was like a slip of tongue.
Nothing bad happened.
He just fell through the window.
Sorry.
It's just a mental typo.
The mental typo, you know.
Hey guys, sorry.
He fell down the window.
There was nothing I could do to save him.
Wait, do I give this to him?
Wait, I have the sensors.
So I can pick to either give it to Richard or the Wards, right?
So that I could pick one or the other, right?
Or like...
Yeah?
Oh, it's my choice?
Alright.
Oh.
Okay, but like who would give the better...
Who would give the better loot though, guys?
Because he doesn't know.
I mean, he knows that it was an accident.
But like...
Who would be the better one?
Do I give it to the Wards or Richard?
Also, I need to use the bathroom.
You guys, make the choice for me.
Look at that radiation!
It's not a sickness, it's a feature.
That's different.
It's not a sickness.
Okay.
Alright, guys.
Have we made our choice?
What are we going for?
The Wards or Richard?
I don't even know what his faction is called.
What are we going for?
The Wards or Richard?
I mean, he's just Richard.
Gun or armor?
Okay, wait.
Maybe armor would be...
The Wards?
Alright, Ward time.
I saw more people...
See, I'm not a bad person.
You guys also picked the Wards.
How am I a bad person if you guys also picked this option?
That says more about you guys than me.
Okay, I'll give you guys a fair vote.
Alright.
The Wardens or the Nerds.
There you go.
There's your fair option.
There it is.
Ow.
Oh my god.
Did I get the barbed wire again?
Fucking hell.
Ew.
Nerds!
How dare you call the free stockers nerds?
Easy answer.
Oh my god.
The nerds are winning?
Do I have nerds watching my stream?
This is a psych-ops.
There is a sign showing I'm a nerd.
Don't keep it I'm a nerd.
Don't say that.
I'm picking nerds to spite you.
Okay.
Alright.
So we're picking Let's see.
So we're picking uh Alright.
So we're gonna pick the nerd faction.
I guess.
They don't know, guys.
They don't know what happened to Oh my god.
I gotta heal up.
They don't know what happened to that guy.
So we're safe.
They just think that he fell out the window.
And that's the story we're gonna go with, chat.
Alright.
Here we go.
Hello.
Oh, I should get some food.
No, that's my iPad.
I should open my food inventory.
Alright.
Gotta eat that sausage so I'm not as hungry.
Oh wait, I got another sausage.
Nice.
Hello.
Yeah, yeah.
We found him.
Can you tell me about the squint?
Yeah, is he a friend?
See, used to.
Used to.
They're not close anymore.
So I'm less guilty.
See?
He's crazy.
He cares about the censors more than him.
I'm not punished.
Now I have zero guilt.
Alright.
Anyway, here's your censors.
Is that all you know?
Yeah.
I didn't kill him.
He fell out the window.
Guys, it was...
I saw him fall out the window.
We're all looking for anomalies!
Is there something we're not looking for?
Like...
What do you mean, what was I doing there?
I'm...
Are we all looking for anomalies?
Like...
Yeah, I remember that little performance.
You could see it from the post office.
Clear as day.
I should have known you had a hand in it.
But we're getting off topic.
Taking the sphere by storm would be even dumber than walking into the zone without any bolts.
I strongly advise against this course of action.
But, I've got an idea.
What?
Wait, why are you helping me?
And I'm supposed to believe that?
If you've got skin in this game, speak up.
If you don't, back off.
We have a responsibility to the people we've rescued, you know?
If you want to go to war against the whole sphere, be my guest.
But first, listen up.
I learned something interesting.
After the wards started raising hell, Suhean ordered his men to sweep the backup communications center under the ribs.
Okay.
Yeah.
Are there monsters there?
Worse.
Evidence of Suhean's illegal activities.
Illegal activities?
What was he doing?
You might be able to find something useful in there.
Something that'll open a door for us.
Oh!
Take a look inside your stash.
Wait, I can give it to...
Also to the...
I can play both sides?!
Let's fucking go!
Oh my god, I should drink some vodka real quick, though.
Oh my god!
Suhean!
Oh, it's your birthday?!
Happy birthday!
Have a bow on the house.
Oh my god!
I can also give the censers to the wardens!
Ah, shit.
Can you stop doing that?
I got it!
Oh!
Oh, whoops!
Okay, I guess not.
Nevermind.
Nevermind, I can't play both sides.
It's already too late.
Nevermind, I gave it to the other guy.
Goddammit.
I thought I could!
Thank you!
I love living in in Glasgow, Chernobyl!
What does a guide do?
Just kidding, my boy.
Just kidding!
Alright.
Why can't he just come with me?
And he could guide me to places.
Like, he's not even doing his job!
What is he gonna do?
Fucking...
Ugh!
I wonder if these can cause damage.
It's like minus one damage every time I chuck it.
Like, god, I have unlimited bolts.
Boom!
Alright.
What's my current mission?
Get into the sphere's abandoned hub.
Alright, we're gonna call it here, actually.
I...
We did it!
We did our job!
We did... Also, I need to rest my voice.
I don't wanna fuck it...
I don't wanna overdo it today!
Chat!
So we're gonna call it here!
Cause I still wanna chat with you guys!
I'm, like, trying to make sure I don't overdo it.
God!
But it's been so fun so far!
I think, like, as this being, like, my first Stalker game, I am confused.
I am, like, confused in some areas, because, like, I don't know if I should have played this as, like, my first game.
Like...
I think, like, it does help that you guys are, like, telling me about the lore of it.
So, like, so, I'm, like, learning it as we go along.
Learning bits about the Stalker universe as we play it, because you guys are, like, helping me with that.
So it is, like, I am, like, understanding a little bit more.
I just think it's very funny that I just think it's very funny that it's based on in, like, you know, in Ukraine, but, like, like, you know, you would think it would be, like, Metro voice acting, where they'll obviously talk in, like, an accent that matches the environment,
but then but...
I love how I love how, like, but instead instead of UK for Ukraine, it's UK for the United Kingdom.
Because everybody's speaking in a British accent.
AHAHAHAHAHAHAHA Yeah!
It's, like, I I don't know why.
Why is everybody speaking Why is, like, why is this guy Scottish?
Um, um, Stalker throws you into deep end no matter which game, but it's probably the least buggy out of all them unless you want to get into mods.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I'm happy that, like, um, we didn't encounter any, like, issues in general, um, because, uh, uh, there wasn't anything uh, uh, regarding, like, bugs that people said they encountered during launch, uh, so it was, like, nice that it was very smooth.
Yeah, it was very smooth because, like, originally people were, like, talking about performance issues, and I wasn't even lagging, too.
Like, I, myself wasn't even lagging while playing it, so that was really good.
Um, Devlin, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Thanks for the stream, Doki!
Uh, missed the beginning because of my family having to, having a birthday dinner for me, but at least I'm here for the end!
Thank you for the super chat, Devlin!
Thank you, thank you!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Devlin!
Nyah!
Happy birthday!
Uh, it's so many people's birthdays today!
I know I missed a birthday earlier.
Let me see if I can find it.
Guys, does anyone remember whose birthday it was?
Guys?
Uh...
I'm looking.
Guys, which one, who was it?
I missed the birthday soupa earlier.
Um, does anyone remember?
Oh my, no.
Well, uh, it's everybody's birthday.
Coyote, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Um, soccer is my favorite game to see, so it's been really fun getting to see you experience it for the first time.
You're amazing, making amazing mercenaries so far!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Uh, thank you, yeah!
It's, it's like fun to experience it blind.
And it definitely made me interested in checking out, um, the first soccer game.
Um, just because like, you know, like, there's like so much, like, history about, around the game.
So I'm like, oh my god, what was it like, what's the lore behind this?
Like, everything and stuff like that.
So, it's definitely very interesting.
Alright, I'm trying to see, uh...
I'm trying to see whose other birthday I missed.
I'm sorry if I missed your birthday soupa!
I remember being like, oh, it's your birthday!
Give me a sec, I'm gonna, I'm gonna fucking figure out how to get through this, please!
It was StardustRaven.
StardustRaven!
Thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, thank you!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Stardust!
Yeah!
I'm sad I didn't hear it.
Cheeky, breeky.
Where, where would they, where would they say that?
Yeah, I saw people, like, like, talking about it in chat.
But I don't know, like, where, in what case, like, we'd get that interaction.
Um...
Uh...
Yeah, it's actually, uh, it's very interesting so far.
Um, I'm, okay, let me see.
In the first stalker?
Oh, no, oh, it's in the bandits?
Okay, let me see.
How long, guys, I'm gonna, how long to complete stalker 2?
Okay, um...
Ahaha!
Um...
Stalker 2 dev says, I mean, we saw the map.
Hahaha!
We saw the map.
Stalker 2 dev says, the game is huge.
It takes 100 hours to fully beat and was built Oh my fucking...
Oh my god.
Oh, anyway.
Speaking of stalker 2.
I have some free codes for you guys.
Yeah.
So you guys stayed up here.
MSI sponsored today's stream.
And because of that, is in order to promote their newest promotion regarding the monitors.
So if you order their monitors, you will get a free copy of stalker 2.
Plus $30 of Steam Wallet.
So this is, again, thank you to MSI for sponsoring today's stream.
I was originally going to play stalker 2 anyway on launch day.
So, you know, it was a great bonus.
You know, a little happy bonus that it was sponsored.
And they provided free game codes for the dragoons.
So I'm going to grab those real quick.
Alright guys, I'm going to give you guys a countdown.
Okay, there's going to be a stream delay actually.
So I'm going to...
I'm going to like...
Wait, you know what would be so fucked up?
If I...
Okay.
Alright.
I'm going to see how fast you guys can type.
For the first one.
So...
Alright.
Let's see.
Game code.
Alright.
Here.
Okay.
Alright.
The first code.
I'm going to type it on screen.
And then we'll see how good you guys are.
Okay.
Here's the first one.
Six.
H.
C.
Nine.
Z.
K.
V.
W5.
763.
J.
Nah, I'm not doing that.
Last letter.
Last...
What would it be?
What would be the last one?
What's the last letter?
What?
W.
Okay, did anyone get it?
Who got it?
That's so evil.
Guess the last letter.
Oh my god.
You monster.
Oh my god, it was already redeemed?
Who got it?
Alright, next one.
This is the next one.
Okay, the next one I'm gonna post it in chat.
Okay, you don't be really evil.
Alright.
Alright, alright.
The next one I'm gonna post it on...
My internet is nowhere fast enough for this.
Alright.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna tweet it.
A person just brute-forced this.
Just give away all the...
Oh, that's fucking evil.
Give away all the codes and I remove the last letter.
Alright.
And it's sticking out.
They had to guess.
Alright, here we go.
I'm posting it in chat.
3...
2...
1...
Boom.
Alright, and the next one.
I'm going to...
Okay, and this one's gonna be fun.
Alright, the next one.
I'm gonna start typing.
The real challenge.
Oh, Alan got another one.
Alan got this one.
Alright.
Okay.
Alright, here's the next one.
5W3KG...
DYE...
JL...
IQ3...
And then the last two I won't...
Now, what would the last two be?
Wait, this is the one I just...
Oh, sorry.
I have to retype this.
I gave you guys the wrong one.
JK...
Gotta retype it.
5...
I was looking at the wrong one.
KG...
DYE...
JL...
6...
KQ...
7...
M...
Alright, who redeemed it?
Oh, I keep forgetting my glasses.
There's no 6, by the way.
I just needed to fix myself.
There's no 5, by the way.
There's no 7, by the way.
Guys...
Oh, Wafflestein got this one.
How am I evil?
I'm literally a pussy.
Alright.
Last one.
Guys.
Alright.
Alright, I'm posting this one in chat.
Make the last one.
What if I reverse it?
What if I give you, like, every...
All 5 digits?
All 5 digits of it?
But then, like, I put them out of order.
Like...
I give you 5...
I just put them all out of order.
And then you have to reorder it yourself.
Dude, that is evil as hell.
No, please don't.
No.
Okay, okay.
Okay, I won't.
I won't do that.
I won't.
Okay, but then it'll give...
It'll give people with slower internet a chance, though.
Guys.
All I'm saying is that...
It'll give, like, people with slower internet a chance.
And then they'll, like, they have...
Okay, so...
I'm gonna give you 5 of each.
And then you're gonna have to...
You're gonna have to guess, like...
The order.
The order of this.
Okay, I'm gonna hide it.
Alright, and then, like, whoever figured it out...
Whoever figured it out, congratulations.
Alright, this is all out of order, by the way.
All of this is out of order.
So you guys have to figure out which one it is.
Alright.
Alright, you guys ready?
I'm gonna put, like...
Alright.
This is the first one.
It's all out of order.
Like, this...
These are all, like...
It's, like, 3...
It's, like, 3 sections of 5 digits.
And they're all...
But they're, like...
The section itself is out of order.
So...
So you gotta figure it out.
No, they're not all.
It's a section.
So...
You gotta figure out which one's first, second, and third.
You gotta figure it out.
Yeah, I'm not doing this.
No, it is possible.
It's literally...
You gotta figure out which is the first section, which is the second, and which is the third.
And then, it's like a puzzle.
You guys love puzzles, right?
And it's literally...
That's why you guys love watching me play Silent Hill.
Oh, it's already activated?
There's no...
It's just...
Yeah, it's 6...
Who solved it?
Who the fuck solved it?
Wait, what was...
I think I got it?
Who got it?
You can't say, I think I got it.
Like, it tells you if you got it or not.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that was fast.
You gotta stop.
It's literally 6 combinations.
Who was it?
Who figured...
Wait, Dresden got it?
Oh my god.
Wait.
Oh my god, that's fast.
But yeah, that was...
I don't remember what the combination was.
This was the correct combination.
See, look at that.
Wasn't that fun, guys?
Guys, wasn't that fun?
This was the correct answer.
Wasn't that fun, everybody?
It's like a little game.
A little game we have.
You guys gotta...
It's like, you know, earning the free code.
Yeah.
But congrats, everybody.
Congratulations to all the dragoons that got the...
That...
I typed that but got too many attempts.
Oh my god.
Anyway.
But yeah.
Thank you again to MSI for sponsoring today's stream.
And for giving out codes for the dragoons.
Another thing to show is the, you know...
For those who don't know, my collection for gamer subs has dropped today.
I haven't tweeted it out yet because I was like going...
I was...
I had so much worse stuff to do.
The fair and the round chances of the last code was 1 to 2,000 viewers.
Giga, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Shadows, thank you for the super chat.
I can't believe I fell out the window, got called a nerd, then lost money to Toki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But...
We have all our products now out...
Now out on gamer subs.
I saw...
I saw people didn't realize that I have a gamer sub code.
So it is...
If you use the code DokiBird or Doki, you get 10% off on your order.
So yeah, like I said earlier, the more people that order the items in this collection...
The more likely I can get my own flavor.
Don't you guys want your own DokiBird drink?
So it really does help out.
We have the shaker cup, the t-shirt, and also the stickers.
The sticker pack contains all the designs.
The only randomness is whichever design is a holographic.
All the designs are included.
So it's not really gotcha.
The only gotcha part of the sticker pack is whichever one is a holographic.
So it includes everything.
It includes all the designs in the sticker pack.
I was reading the description and even I was confused.
So I was like, oh shit, like...
Oh shit, is it the chances of getting the sticker gotcha or something?
And they were like, oh no.
And I was like, okay, clarify it.
So they clarified it in the description.
So in the description, now it says it includes all five base set designs.
So all of them.
So they redid the description because even I was confused.
I was like, wait a minute.
I didn't want it gotcha.
I wanted everybody to put gotcha for it.
So I'm glad they changed the description.
But now it's more clear as to what it is.
Nabi, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Preorder your waifu cup.
Can't wait for it.
Yay, thank you.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm super excited.
I'm really excited.
It's free.
You can't say that.
That code, the game code I gave was free.
This is paid.
Literally, it's like complaining about free roll and gotcha.
Heaven, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Fun way to spend my birthday evening.
Thank you for the stream, Doki.
P.S.
It was also PhantomDragon's birthday.
Oh my god, okay.
Happy birthday to you.
Thank you for the superchat.
Happy birthday, dear Phantom.
Happy birthday to you.
Yeah, happy birthday, Phantom.
There's so many people's birthdays.
But yeah, it's been a wild ride.
My voice is dead because I am still recovering.
Oh my god, did you guys see that?
Did you guys see the fucking gamer recap?
YouTube gamer recap thing?
I thought that was AI.
Like the Doki Bird's return.
I didn't realize they actually made a section for me there.
I thought it was AI.
I legitimately did not think it was like a thing they made themselves to promote me.
I was so fucking surprised.
Because I was just thinking like...
Yeah, I didn't realize!
I was so...
I was actually like really shocked.
Because when I first saw people tweeting about it...
I was like, oh that's cool.
You know like the summary AI thing?
I thought it was literally that.
I thought it was like the summary AI where...
Also, here's my thing for those who want to...
Here's the collection, guys.
So like I thought that...
The Dragoons were there to watch Doki Bird's return.
Was like some summary AI thing that they made.
But I didn't realize that YouTube actually personally wrote that section about it.
So I was like, holy fuck.
Like I...
YouTube noticed me.
But that was so cool.
That was really, really cool.
Um...
Slug, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for every super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the stream today.
As a long time fan of the soccer game, seeing your first reaction today...
We're almost as good as...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, I think like...
Is everything just an anomaly?
Like...
Just like, are you an anomaly?
Am I an anomaly?
What is an anomaly here?
Everything is a fucking anomaly.
Like...
Anyway...
Are we the anomalies?
But yes, there's so much stuff...
To show today.
So much stuff to show at the moment.
So it's just like...
Oh my god, I'm just like...
Not overwhelmed...
But I'm like really busy.
And like...
There's so much work to catch up on too.
So...
I wish I could hang out longer.
But I have to recover my voice.
Because like...
I have to record stuff.
And I can't record anything.
Because my voice is dying.
I felt so bad.
Um...
Anyway...
I don't know if tomorrow there's going to be a stream.
I might put a schedule up for the last...
Two days.
Because Friday would be a collab with...
Doobie and Filian.
And then Saturday would be the announcement for the custom.
Um...
So yeah, we'll see how it goes.
I might put a schedule up today.
I think I might take tomorrow off.
Just to heal my throat a little bit more.
Anyway guys, as always...
I really missed you guys.
I missed streaming.
I wish I wasn't sick so I could keep streaming.
I really... I hate...
I hate taking breaks.
I just want to stream.
But as always everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.